AT THE #"THE STORY."
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.
TUCKER IS UP.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
WITHIN MINUTES OF THE
PARKLAND MASSACRE THE MEDIA
IDENTIFIED A VILLAIN.
WASN'T THE 19-YEAR-OLD WHO
PULLED THE TRIGGER.
CNN PUBLISHED A PIECE
SCOLDING THE PRESIDENT FOR
CALLING HIM CRAZY U THE REAL
KILLER WAS THE NRA ALONG
WITH MILLIONS OF LAW ABIDING
GUN OWNERS, BLOOD WAS ON
THEIR HANDS.
WELL, A FEW DAYS LATER NOW
THAT WE HAVE SOME FACTS.
IT TURNS OUT IT'S NOT SO
SIMPLE.
IT TURNS OUT THAT GOVERNMENT
AT ALL LEVELS PLAYED A ROLE
IN ALLOWING THIS MASSACRE TO
HAPPEN.
IN FACT, A MUCH LARGER ROLE
THAN WE KNEW OR WOULD HAVE
EVER GUESS YOU HAD.
THE DETAILS ARE SHOCKING.
HERE IS PART OF WHAT WE KNOW
SO FAR.
THE BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE RECEIVED AT LEAST 23
CALLS RELATED TO NIKOLAS
CRUZ AND HIS FAMILY.
IN 2016 A DEPUTY WAS TOLD
DIRECTLY THAT CRUZ WAS
THREATENING TO SHOOT UP HIS
SCHOOL.
THE ONE HE SHOT UP.
AND HAD TAKEN PHOTOGRAPHS OF
HIMSELF WITH FIREARMS.
THAT INFORMATION WAS
FORWARDED TO DEPUTY SCOTT
PETERSON.
THAT NAME SOUNDS FAMILIAR,
THAT IS THE EXACT SECURITY
GUARD AT STONEMAN DOUGLAS
HIGH SCHOOL WHO HID OUTSIDE
DURING THE SHOOTING AND
REFUSED TO GO INSIDE AS 17
PEOPLE WERE MURDERED.
APPARENTLY DOING NOTHING WAS
A HABIT OF PETERSON'S.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WEIGHED IN
ON HIM TODAY ON HIS WAY TO
CPAC.
WATCH.
>> WHEN IT CAME TIME TO GO
IN THERE AND DO SOMETHING,
HE DIDN'T HAVE THE COURAGE
OR SOMETHING HAPPENED BUT HE
CERTAINLY DID A POOR JOB.
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT.
HE WAS THERE FOR FIVE
MINUTES, FOR FIVE MINUTES.
THAT WAS DURING THE ENTIRE
SHOOTING.
HE HEARD IT RIGHT AT THE
BEGINNING.
SO HE CERTAINLY DID A POOR
JOB.
BUT THAT'S THE CASE WHERE
SOMEBODY WAS OUTSIDE.
THEY'RE TRAINED.
THEY DIDN'T REACT PROPERLY
UNDER PRESSURE OR THEY WERE
A COWARD.
>> Tucker: SCOTT PETERSON
MAY NOT HAVE BEEN THE ONLY
COWARD ON THE SCENE.
BRAND NEW REPORTS SUGGEST
THREE OTHER BROWARD COUNTY
DEPUTIES ARRIVED AT THE
SCHOOL DURING THE MASSACRE
BUT DID NOT ENTER OR ATTEMPT
TO PURSUE CRUZ.
INSTEAD THEY HID OUTSIDE
BEHIND THEIR VEHICLES UNTIL
CORAL SPRINGS OFFICERS
ARRIVED AND FOUND THEM.
ACTION APPEARS TO BE A
DEFINING QUALITY IN THE
BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE.
LAST DECEMBER BROWARD COUNTY
WAS WARNED THAT CRUZ WAS A
SCHOOL SHOOTER IN THE MAKING
AND COLLECTING WEAPONS WITH
WHICH TO DO IT.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN WRITE A
REPORT ON THE TIP.
INSTEAD THEY TOLD THE
TIPSTER TO REPORT CRUZ TOUT
PALM BEACH COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE.
THOSE HOW LOCAL POLICE
RESPONDED OR DIDN'T RESPOND.
THE STATE WASN'T MUCH
BETTER.
LATER IN 2016, DESPITE
EVIDENCE OF SUICIDAL
BEHAVIOR BY CRUZ, IN HIS
EXPRESSIONED DESIRE TO BUY A
FIREARM, THE FLORIDA
DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES DECIDED THAT
SOMEHOW HE WAS NOT A THREAT
TO HIMSELF OR OTHERS.
IF THEY DECIDED OTHERWISE,
CRUZ WOULD HAVE BEEN
INVOLUNTARILY COMMITTED AND
WOULD HAVE BEEN BARRED FROM
BUYING A GUN.
IN CASE YOU ARE WONDERING
HOW WAS THIS GUY ABLE TO BUY
A GUN?
THAT'S HOW.
THEN THERE IS THE FBI, THE
FEDS.
IN SEPTEMBER OF 2017, THE
FBI WAS WARNED THAT A
YOUTUBE USER NAMED NIKOLAS
CRUZ SPELLED CORRECTLY HAD
WRITTEN THIS, QUOTE:  I'M
GOING TO BE A PROFESSIONAL
SCHOOL SHOOTER.
HE WROTE THAT ONLINE.
THE FBI NOW SAYS THAT WAS
NOT ENOUGH INFORMATION TO
IDENTIFY WHO MADE THAT
REMARK AND THEY WERE UNABLE
TO INVESTIGATE DESPITE THE
FACT THAT CRUZ GAVE HIS REAL
NAME, SPELLED IN THE UNUSUAL
WAY THAT IT IS SPELLED.
IN JANUARY 2018, THE FBI WAS
WARNED AGAIN THAT CRUZ WAS
PLANNING TO SHOOT UP A
SCHOOL AND WERE GIVEN
SPECIFIC INFORMATION ABOUT
HIS ERRATIC BEHAVIOR, HIS
GUN-COLLECTING, HIS
EXPRESSED DESIRE TO KILL
PEOPLE.
DID HE NOT HIDE THAT THE
TIPSTER WARNED THAT CRUZ
WAS, QUOTE:  GOING TO
EXPLODE AND WORRIED IT WAS
JUST A MATTER OF TIME BEFORE
HE, QUOTE, WAS IN A SCHOOL
AND SHOOTING THE PLACE UP.
THE CALLER ALSO TOLD THE FBI
THAT SHE MADE THE CALL
BECAUSE SHE WANTED A, QUOTE,
CLEAR CONSCIENCE IF HE TAKES
OFF AND JUST STARTS SHOOTING
PLACES UP IN RESPONSE THE
FBI DID NOTHING.
THEY DIDN'T BOTHER TO
FORWARD THAT TIP TO A FIELD
OFFICE.
THE SCHOOL SYSTEM FAILED AS
WELL AND BADLY.
IN 2013, SCHOOL OFFICIALS
DECIDED TO RADICALLY CUT
DOWN ON IN SCHOOL ARRESTS
CLAIMING THAT SCHOOL
DISCIPLINE WAS RACIALLY
BIASED.
THE SCHOOL SIMPLY STOPPED
REFERRING STUDENTS TO POLICE
FOR ASSAULT AND DRUG USE AND
NUMEROUS OTHER CRIMES,
ACTUAL CRIMES.
TOTAL ARRESTS DECLINED FOR
MORE THAN A THOUSAND A YEAR
TO FEWER THAN 400.
SO IN SPITE OF GETTING IN
TROUBLE WITH SCHOOL
AUTHORITIES REPEATEDLY, CRUZ
WAS NEVER ARRESTED, HE WAS
NEVER CHARGED.
NEVER CONVICTED, NEVER
STOPPED FROM BUYING A GUN.
THE SCHOOLS FAILED, THE
LOCAL POLICE FAILED, THE
FLORIDA STATE BUREAUCRACY
FAILED, THE OFFICER ON DUTY
FAILED, THE FBI FAILED U THE
GOVERNMENT'S FIRST DUTY IS
PROTECTING ITS CITIZENS.
THEY FAILED.
ULTIMATELY CITIZENS HAVE TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES.
THE MESSAGE COULD NOT BE
CLEARER.
YET, THE SAME GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS WHO FAILED TO